yoga's what is up prestige here and
today we got another episode of the
urban experience which is ignore this my
channel / series just some me going
around a little bit of hair burn active
and just doing some cool stuff so last
episode we had just found a abandoned
mine shaft which you see here and I was
quite happy because that means good loot
very good okay I think I was over there
before because there's some callosum how
does it make sure ah well it is early in
the morning will not early kind of early
hello zombies a lot zombies have to turn
the sound out of it or you don't okay
yeah there is I think we got them all
let's get it is it gets margarine hook
but yeah so what all you guys are still
enjoying the series you seem to be so as
you can turn sound down you seem to be
enjoying the series so that is Gouda and
so as yeah long as you guys keep
enjoying it I'll keep doing and you guys
got are there any other big suggestions
then let me know and I will do my best
to see I can do them if you guys have
good suggestions of those look like oh
ok get we go on with you cowboy who's
ombu go zombie multiple zombies are I
got this yeah I tried him dalada that
knockbacks for that would work
ow dad's a bad bad hey I gave these
crutch put them in this thing and this
cowboy come falling like it quits Chris
look spin cut a little 30 awesome I have
him a little third glass episode totally
forgot death to the Skeletor Scott or
dead dead dead dead yeah it's cool in a
hour so subtle that I'm like it I got
some time do with urban experience I
probably not gonna have much time over
this weekend because i'm actually in
marching band and if you guys you should
know what that is um i guess if you're
like not in high school you don't have
like a good idea what it is maybe i
don't know but basically it's a band
that's on the it goes on the football
field and marches around stuff and they
have I'm not sure our other martial
bands but for my marshall mann we
practice a lot i'll bet up his mug yep
yep pissed him off all gender pearl I
can't hold it uh and that's loud I feel
I don't need that well least hidden like
teleport and we'd like a fight him like
when he's all jumping around on us it
was just straight-up paragraph was brawl
about their knuckles I mean with iron
armor there were times over because that
is the most bare knuckles that you could
have I ever ha alright alright so I'm
looking like wanna fun oh I want to find
the Guru chesty chests cuz i found the
chesty chests and I get the girly goods
oh the floor
what this is it going into a ravine all
the juice on that's legit I always loved
me intersect with each other oh there's
a lot of the spawner whoo well then I'm
not gonna go over there oh hello I do
not want to fight case letters in this
case brothers or my mortal enemy all
right I notice a margin on the other
side will have to forgo it in here so uh
oh great Bert Cooper's not that curves I
did oh gosh i hear spiders bro bro you
kind of annoying bro bro first time
annoying hmm Oh see I think I've been
here before Hyup Hyup I mean more
torches to have more torches I'll have
more towards to animate them I guess no
don't say let's mix would like that in
the sticks and without the coal jump now
I'm stuck daughters buh-buh-buh-buh-buh
then and now mean to play with start
doing the morrow song when I started
that just gonna happen and happen
naturally like that iron
come on we want to find ourselves chest
so we can get that horse armor and all
your good stuff I so say I ok there we
go up to explore yeah I think there were
any monsters within waiting in silence
to kidding me ya know and I'm into place
that all right let's see what as well as
well Mike well we need the goods good
man this is another ravine dang auto
same routine he just over there's okay
okay yeah I'm here lots of [ __ ] knobs
explain oh this is the same thing as
that before okay okay okay this is where
the creeper blew up or well somehow I
made back of that I dropped down let's
go explore let's go slow and bro our
place where no place the torch there and
that breaks it dude ah nothing sadness
is our X mizner yep who to shouted son
missing damaged and just just just full
oh that's nice don't really want any
cool because i have a lot of coal who
would like a job perk or are i think
i've made it over to the other side
without the crossing case letters so
that it good anything done here yes no I
lied where's gonna believe me come on
guys she's known as lying there's
obviously nothing down there seriously
it's more iron nope that sort of not got
it I'm gonna upstairs or iron little ran
a poll and place it over to pin it well
this is just proven to be one amazing
behind shaft come on but that heck I
want like good give me the goons bro
give me the huge place place place place
all come on I've learned nothing like
one chest or like library our librarian
strongholds or structure or anything
like what the heck all right let's check
on this way big smiles there's nothing
miners water but because there's a
little water particles I've been ago bro
I wore my key bro forgive me I'm water
particle there was no I thought I'd seen
any way to get up over there all right
let's just go up and go that way nope
well let's let the water flow there
wasn't one who won it's cool all right
now we can oh god block at the door
chatter and torch ice there's a little
water um it's looking like there's
nothing there there's no no no I'm
adding no no no poke okay just deceive
me I can't get that iron um anything
special right here or is just like a
sanctuary to the LOB okay whatever bro I
don't worship lobby you can I don't um
let's see this is just like it this way
hang up voice you saw me there I'll miss
up to let me do that let's see i'm due
to 220 crepes clip i heard your grapes
creeps all this case head right there ok
smite out oh one shot nice little creeps
all what the why can you blow up there
weren't even at my level we've not my
level son ah my lord ago lots of mobs
with that I want to be up there see
there any place to go no some robber put
me right there no so this seems like
I've explored all of this branch oh oh
yep yep I thought it was something that
wasn't there was nothing oh oh no I
haven't I haven't oh gosh Oh would that
scared me bad spider and there is still
nothing what a surprise what the heck
one sec I'm just checking my phone to
see if enough alright guys well I'll
make sure I wasn't need all right well I
know this wasn't the most part explored
this thought has just gone back here all
right guys Oh Endermen I know this
wasn't the most exciting episode I know
we just like searching for stuff but I I
do hope you have enjoyed and
and they should give me a stack of yeah
there should be a stack hope you'll
enjoy it if you got this far I'm hope
I'm just leaving you enjoyed it so
please leave a like rate comment or
subscribe okay can't look at that end of
it all right yeah I like rate comment or
subscribe since I would all be
appreciated next episode I think we're
going to make our great attack on the
cave spider spawner do this you're just
on 110 is that far away I think so
alright guys hope you enjoyed and I'm
I'm prestige and I'll see you later
Wow
I